sie kann auch genau da hin dass du
brauchst du mir gedacht okay craig
machen wir noch länger einfach nur weil
wir es können
was links habe ich von kontron fielen
jährlich dazu stadt gehalten
er verklagt und jung ich scheiße was
machen wir nur meine tür ist voll
ineffizient ich muss eine schaltung
brown habe ich habe das gefühl dass
darunter mein keller ich habe sogar noch
achter und der ist aber ich glaube ich
hab kein rebell mehr kein rebell mehr
platz auch bei mir so viel abgefahren
sagst du vielleicht ein buntes dich weg
noch was hier der kef hat vielleicht
sogar noch recht welche er brauchte das
habe ich jetzt gemacht was richtig aber
geil aus was es geht ja nicht mal ein
wunderschönes gemälde mit einem stein
backen
obama kann das ab machen und dann geht
es wieder jetzt hast du einen
bilderrahmen ein bilderrahmen mit einem
button liegt vor dir ist fasten
er ist unseren das erste update liegt
vor dir dann aus dem affekt sollte ich
geupdatet special feature das ist
unsichtbar sein easter egg von den extra
eingebaut
aber er lässt marie hier geht sie
richtig arbeiten da immer auf
aktuellsten stand depping
irgendwann erlaubt sich den spaß macht
feuer zu macht lama zum wasser und
wasser zu lava red wer fantastisch
block aufwand denn dadurch wird dein
leben
dadurch wird ein tristes leben auch
nicht bunter mein freund hat mal ich
habe jetzt hier die dings hingesetzt
sowie morgen travel hier und hier wieder
gremmel
ich weiß jetzt greven oder nicht ich hab
64 4
das reicht ich weiß nicht ob das reicht
was nicht reich wird reichend gemacht
oder so ich nehme diesen preis nicht an
ganz schön steife brise hier den
schönsten hasse was man irgendwie falsch
platziert crafter er ist so doof mdr
steht immer boxt nicht im weg dazu
müssen gleich schon wieder schlafen
kompletten taten nun mit miss
verbrachten ihre ja noch gar kein thema
bequatscht ach ja ja wir sind aber schon
wieder einen neuen folge sind schon mal
minute 18 das heißt thema dem thema dna
der den als ein thema ok welche
kommentare bringen euch zur weißglut
kommentar von die kubas welche
kommentare bringen uns zu was zur
weißglut er verstand zu plastal sowas
wenn du so ein kommentar ist und denke
so erster wenn man nicht erster ist auch
da die diskussion darum also von wegen
geht ich erhängt was ist denn ich war
noch ein erster habe mich gefreut über
das neue haft blabla allein darüber
diese ganzen diskussion zu führen ist
schrecklich dass alles anzusehen vor
allem diese ganze beleidigungen wieder
ausgeschöpft werden man so schön ich bin
harmoniebedürftiger mensch ich nicht
aber ich bin trotzdem wird es nervt ein
klein wenig was sonst noch so so
wer keine ahnung jetzt allgemein auf
youtube bezogen aya medany uns vor allem
also eigentlich nur unterteilen videos
also wenn du das liest und jetzt hast du
noch dritten da müssen nämlich zwei hin
hab ich nicht was hast du überhaupt was
hast du überhaupt das bald wirklich
nicht so denke ich mir das denn kommt
erstmal schlafen ja also zum beispiel
auch noch sonst server werbung wenn ihr
mir drauf steht er ja mal auf apache
server blablabla sind ganz toller server
in eurer dabei das 0 relevanz zum video
hat und genau das gleiche mit mit kanal
werbung wo man einfach sieht dass ein
text den sie kopiert haben und überall
dann eingefügt haben bei mir sind
zombies
das finde ich auch nicht rechtlich in
kommentaren ja wenn ich also dabei wir
sind echt ziemlich offen daches soll das
denn vielleicht ausleuchten das mal ic
natürlich bei complus herdorf ich habe
eine junge ich habe eine a ha den hat
ein ips zurück
so geht's nicht
mit meiner wunder spitze kaputt gebashe
ha ha ha ha ha ja ich war grad so oft
jetzt kaum schlafen gut bis 100 er auch
im bett nein da bin ich also überlegt
wenn jetzt tag wird dann dann ist er
doch im bett gewesen
oder was mich auch nervt wenn video
antworten gepostet werden ist ja nicht
auch 1 kommentar bei youtube ist ja wie
ein kommentar wenn meine video antwort
macht ihn nicht zum thema zu tun haben
warum bekommt dauern video antworten zur
together show oder so zu irgendwas ist
da ebenso komischen sachen zu was ja und
was denken sie sind als ob ich das
annehme oder was man auch gericht
teilweise per nachricht zugesendet zu
video empfehlungen von so amerikanern
die sich dann irgendeinen scheiß die mir
dann irgendwie scheiß zu senden
von wegen ja wirklich keine ahnung dass
eine total behindert was hattest du
jetzt noch karten treppen oder nicht
wenn man sagt ich habe es cobblestone
die du solltest allerdings nach gucken
auch noch revel bei ok mit kmw
eigentlich jetzt relativ genug wir
können uns hier passt ja auch viele
leute gesagt haben macht bei folge 100
oder so mit allen leuten bisher da waren
eine folge
da muss ich sofort sagen dass es wird
nicht umsetzbar sein bzw
nicht mit allen weil bis dahin wenn
jeder gast den folgen da oder so erst
ein locker weise nicht wenn wir es
alleine machen neun gäste oder acht
gäste oder in die so dass das die alle
zusammen zeit finden ist schon heftig
man kann es probieren aber das wird er
nicht
vor allem jetzt nicht bei dem nächsten
gast den wir haben die haben ja schon
fest geplant sondern bei dem gast der
danach kommt ist es sehr schwierig zeit
zu finden weil wir das jetzt schon
gesagt habe ich ab denen du weißt ja
nicht mein oder ja okay weil ich habe
ihnen letztes gefragt vor weil sie nicht
anderthalb bis zwei wochen wenn er zeit
hat er material wurden drei vier wochen
holt euch erstmal andere gäste und das
heißt schon dass da dann die haben wenig
zeit gleich mal so obwohl der das sogar
schon mal bei sich selbst gemacht hat
volker habermaier holt sich jeder
irgendwie mag es einfach mal ich hier
die kommt daher danke
allen möchte den anderen den spaß kaputt
das sollte doch gerade deswegen spieler
die auch alle spieler hier spoiler ist
sogar beim jugendwort des jahres dabei
was war das früher nicht so bekannt oder
warum ich jetzt spoiler und mein gott da
hinten steht auch der stein baum den ich
mal gemacht habe da hat mein kompakten
baum ab gefällt und hatte nicht seinen
ab gefällt habe ich einfach stein
hingesetzt dachte es ist eine brücke wo
er ich habe grübel und so treml und
sabrina steinen ich habe steine
in meinem haus und in deinem haus und im
haus von minecraft pakets auch eine
längerfristig sogar denn gebaut dann
geht es mit dem vertrauen meisten der
minecraft pocket steht ihr noch im warum
versteht er jesus park steht ja noch der
baut immer noch seine in eine richtung
baustelle schon mit konkreter den
treppen reicht das sebastian vettel
gewinnt fast musste hier die meisten
chefs londoner zeitung gelöscht jedoch
schon fest ob es in den usa geschaffen
und ich weiß dass hier am samstagabend
auf es ist der 27
dsds 23.7 verbands ängste und in der
zukunft lebt in der zukunft der 17
zur story vorfeld schon hier so machen
wollen wir der minecraft backhaus
einfach vergewaltigen zu den zwar machen
wir das ja eigentlich so lange ich
dachte bude kommt hier hin da die können
auch genau das gesagt du brauchst eine
kreml und dann dachte okay klarmachen
weg noch länger
einfach nur weil wir es können ja aber
ich hatte erst ja auch gedacht ihm
nehmen das haus aber einen baum welcher
komplett um und es ist alles weg ich
würde es eher als bunker stehen lassen
ja lasst uns aber den weg mit seinem
haus verbinden
das können wenn man ruhe super idee
da genau die mitte da geht der weg dann
quasi durch stimmt wir müssen natürlich
austria tor durchgangs haus genau hier
das heißt hier muss brand gerettet
werden
ich darf ich mal ein feuerzeug immer
einfach brand gerodet mal warte ich
meine sachen aus wasserstoff bauen wir
das ich bin ich irgendetwas
extravagantes habe ich gerade schon
verein blätter haus wo er so schön und
witzig sind echt teilhaber das ist voll
gut so sowohl böden so aus diesem ding
salta sie gar schlecht aus das kannst du
machen dann kann ich machen du das
machen erst die baumstämme bin ja für
einen riesigen penis welt der dann
endlich mal auch einsieht ja komm her du
bist immer im haus gegangen
jetzt muss ich dich bin ich drin bereits
in meinem haus ich glaube ich nicht
darüber sein schüttel automatisch zu
jetzt geht mir irgendwas hoch oder
die engagiert dann schaue ich habe
nichts genommen
ja wieso läuft so schnell weg das
spiegelt das wider was daimler gibt
viele faktoren die aufnahmen wenn man
ich hab dich und ich würde jetzt gern
inventar zeigen aber dann töte ich dich
einfach herrlich kann von hier in einen
eingang prüfung von hier unten
ja und guck mal wer hier ist der coole
junge das modell ppp angelaufen
hallo hast du deine tour beendet
jahrhundert durch nachwuchs bekommen
seine exotischen touran viele abonnenten
homepage schon hat nachher mal
nachschauen nachher voll
denn die richter ins zeug draußen lass
das mal wirklich im kopf sein heutiger
ganzen lp und dann bekommt der typ der
den kanal macht sogar pusch vielleicht
fängt er deswegen mit let's play dann
wird er irgendwann von welchen immer
entdeckt dann wird er richtig richtig
groß raus kommt ja war für herzlich
jetzt hab ich auch nicht gesagt mich
schon immer was hältst du von muscheln
immer kommentar frage ernsthaft von der
junge mcg
diese frage beantworte ich jetzt nicht
weil wegen gibt's was sagst du gibt es
der juror gmc mein gott minecraft backen
hat sein haus auf irgendwelchen
komischen höhlen gebaut ich keine hobbys
der typ es gibt auf jeden fall der junge
der junge war es gibt auch den atv den
kanal steht ja dass man kann aber den
habe ich mir schon mal gesichert hiervon
wegen weil nicht auseinander nimmt steht
esther oder städte ich dachte schon zwar
kommt macht für die zweite alben wie
können sich ernennen den atv es doch
ganz gut an
schon vergeben von st aber das schaffe
ich den sprung mit einem sexy alter wie
sonst das an die brandrodung das greift
auf mein haus über echt blöd manche
sachen verbrannt vielleicht nein das
nichts verbrannt darauf geachtet
frage von der junge emc warum muss
eigentlich konter immer den abrecht
töten ist er irgendwie vorerst jds ja
ich will eine aufmerksamkeit
bshd verrücktes jürgen sind rom
jetzt werden hier die sniper ausgepackt
pass bloß auf treffe ich mal treffe mich
doch treffen obst getroffen was auf dein
haus meine geisel
ich breche ich zu nissan alter natürlich
dein haus an
dann hör bloß auf
ich kann wollen die effektive
brandrodung wollen wir noch einmal
trifft dann wenn er mich noch einmal
triffst dann werde ich das haus anzünden